THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY WERE JOINED BY THE REVENUE
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE DISCUSSED
THE GOVERNOR'S EITC EXPANSION
AND TAX CONFORMING PROPOSAL.
TODAY'S HEARING IS INFORMATIONAL
OR REPEAT INFORMATIONAL ONLY
ALONG AS THE CHANCE TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT THESE PROPOSALS AND
PROVIDE SOME INITIAL THOUGHTS.
THE ASSEMBLY HAS BEEN A STRONG
PROPONENT OF CREATING A SPENDING
THE I. T. THE CAL EITC.
IT'S EXCITING TO SEE THE
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE PROGRAM.
I KNOW STAKEHOLDERS IN THE AUDIO
LET US IN DIFFERENT IDEAS OF HOW
TO EXPAND THE PROGRAM BUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IT'S A GREAT
STARTING PLACE FOR THIS
CONVERSATION.
MORE CHALLENGING THE CONFORMING
PROVISIONS THAT FUND THE ITC
EXPANSION.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDE A
LARGE TAX CUTS TO UPPER INCOME
FAMILIES IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TAX REFORM BILL IT ALSO INCLUDES
A PROVISION.
THAT REDUCING TAX CREDITS FOR
THE SAME TAXPAYERS TO PARTIALLY
OFFSET THE COST OF THE OVERALL
PACKAGE.
WE'RE CONSIDERING CONFORMING TO
SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS.
IN MANY CASES THE TAXPAYERS ARE
SUBJECT TO THE PROVISIONS HAVE
RECEIVED AT LARGE REDUCTION IN
OTHER PARTS OF THEIR FEDERAL TAX
LIABILITIES.
THEY'VE COME OUT WAY AHEAD.
SO CONFORMANCE PROVISIONS THE
STATE LEVEL MAY NOT ADVERSELY
IMPACT THEIR OVERALL SAID TEXAS
RATIONS.
IN BY CONFORMING WE SIMPLIFY THE
TAX PLANNING FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
BUT SOME CAL FOR TAXPAYERS ARE
DISCOVERING NOT ALL TAXPAYERS IF
YOU THE BENEFIT THIS MASSIVE
FEDERAL TAX CUTS.
WE DON'T WANT TO INCREASE TAXES
ON THOSE INDIVIDUALS A SECOND
TIME.
IF WE CAN SIMPLY MISTRESSES
CONFIRM RIPPLES ALL WE NEED TO
PAY ATTENTION TO THE DETAILS OF
EVERY LINE SO WE KNOW WHO'S
IMPACTED IN HOUSE.
THAT WAY WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE MAKING INFORMACIóN.
BEFORE WE DO THAT I WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND CAN WE STILL AS A
QUORUM PLEASE.
UBER HERE CHIU.
LACKEY.
THIS AREA WICKS.
I ONE OF WELCOME IS BURKE CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
pIN THE OPENING COMMENTS THIS
BURKE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER --
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW I'M FEDERAL TAX CONFORMITY
CAN GET VERY COMPLICATED VERY
QUICKLY.
AND SO I'M HOPING THAT THIS
HEARING WILL GIVE US A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING ALONG WITH MORE
DETAILS OF SOME OF THE FEDERAL
PROVISIONS NOTED --
IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
TYPICALLY I THINK WE'RE ALL
INTERESTED IN GETTING MORE
DETAILS ABOUT THE PROPOSED
OPPORTUNITY ZONES PROVISION AS
WELL AS WHY CERTAIN FEDERAL
PROVISIONS WERE CHOSEN LINE
OTHER THINGS WERE LEFT OUT.
AND ALTHOUGH I AM AN ADVOCATE OF
THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT I
WOULD LIKE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY THE
GOVERNOR HAS CHOSEN TO PAIR OF
FEDERAL TAX FOR CONFORMITY WITH
THE EXPANSION OF THE ATC --
I WOULD ALSO I'M WE'RE ALSO
HOPING TO GET THE FINISHED
PRODUCT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE SO
OBVIOUSLY --
WE ONLY HAVE ABOUT SEVENTY DAYS
FOR US TO THAT WE NEED IT BEFORE
SO THAT WE CAN PROPERLY REVIEW
IT AS AN ASSEMBLY AND I THINK
THAT THIS BODY WITH THE CONFLICT.
WITH IS COMPLICATED AN ISSUE AS
IT IS DOES NEED TIME TO REVIEW
THAT.
I LOOK FOR TO THE HEARING FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO ME IMPACT
BE IMPACTED BY THIS PROPOSAL AS
WE MOVE FOR WITH THE HEARING I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
FOR HAVING US AND THANKS TO THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE TODAY THIS
IS AT IT CONFORMITY IS A VERY
COMPLICATED ISSUE AND IT IS
GOING TO TAKE TIME.
THIS IS SOME AS AN ASSEMBLY HAVE
NOT ACTUALLY HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DEAL WITH THIS BEFORE SO.
THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
IT WAS PART OF FIRST AUTUMN
ISSUE ONE GOVERNOR'S WORKING
FAMILIES TAX CREDIT AND TESTING
FOR ME PROPOSAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS JJ ABRAMS DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
AND I WANNA THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY --
TO PRESENT THE GOVERNOR'S
CONFORMITY EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT EXPANSION OF PACKAGE.
AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL.
OF THAT PACKAGE INCLUDES AN
EXPANSION OF THE EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT.
AND AND THE TAX CONFORMITY
PACKAGE WILL RAISE ENOUGH
REVENUE BILLION DOLLARS TO PAY
FOR THE CURRENT AND EXISTING
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT.
WE'RE COMBINING THESE TWO
PROVISIONS BECAUSE WITHOUT THE
CONFORMITY PACKAGE THERE'S NO
WAY TO PAY FOR THE EXPANSION OF
THE OF THE EITC.
THIS COMBINED CONFORMITY EITC
PACKAGE IS AN INTEGRAL PART OF
THE BALANCED AND RESILIENT
BUDGET THAT THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED.
IN IN JANUARY.
I WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE A
SUMMARY OF THE PROVISIONS
INCLUDED IN THE EIGHTY SI
EXPANSION.
AS WELL AS A BRIEF DISCUSSION OF
THE CONFORMITY PACKAGE AND EACH
HAS PROVISIONS AND I'M ASSUMING
THAT SUCH QUICK.
QUESTIONS AND DISCUSSION WE CAN
GET INTO SOME MORE THE DETAILS.
I WANT TO START WITH THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT.
THE CAL THE ATC THE COST OF
LIVING REFUND.
WOULD EXTEND IT WOULD EXPAND THE
CURRENT EITC IN THREE WAYS.
FIRST IT SETS THE MAXIMUM INCOME.
TO QUALIFY FOR THE CREDIT AT
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH IS
THE FULL TIME OF WHICH IS A FULL
TIME AND WAIT FOR SOMEONE
EARNING FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR.
AND IF HE DOES THAT FOR ALL
TAXPAYERS INCLUDING THOSE WHO
HAVE NO DEPENDENTS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE MAXIMUM
INCOME FOR THE EIGHTY SI.
HIS LESSON SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THOSE WITH NO
DEPENDENTS AND THIS LESSON
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
TAXPAYERS WITH DEPENDENTS.
OUR PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO LEAVE
THE MAXIMUM INCOME AT THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY TWO OR WIN THE THE STATE
WIDE.
OF MINIMUM WAGE KICKS IN AT AT
FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER HOUR --
THE MAXIMUM INCOME AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WOULD BE INDEXED TO
INFLATION.
OUR PROPOSAL ALSO CREATES AN
ADDITIONAL CREDIT. FOR FAMILIES
WITH A CHILD UNDER THE AGE OF
SIX A FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
FAMILY.
THIS ADDITIONAL CREDIT IS PHASED
OUT EVENLY BETWEEN TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO IT IN THE
SAME PLACE WHERE THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT WOULDN'T.
AND FINALLY THE STRUCTURE OF THE
CREDIT IS CHANGED SO THAT
HOUSEHOLDS.
IN THE UPPER HALF OF THE EARNED
INCOME TAX INCOME RANGE.
BOTH THOSE WITH AND WITHOUT A
QUALIFYING DEPENDENTS WILL
RECEIVE A LARGER BENEFIT.
AS HE E. I. T. C. INCOME RATE
HAS BEEN EXPANDED IN THE PAST
TWO YEARS THOSE IN THE EXPANDED
INCOME RANGE.
RECEIVE RELATIVELY MINOR --
A CREDIT AMOUNTS AVERAGING
AROUND A HUNDRED A HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS --
FOR FOR HOUSEHOLD WITH DEPENDENT.
FOR HOUSEHOLDS WITH NO
DEPENDENTS.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS WITH MORE
GENEROUS CREDIT ALMOST FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS MORE --
IN SOME CASES.
THE CAL EITC THE COST OF LIVING
REFUND IS EXPECTED TO COST ABOUT
A BILLION DOLLARS ROUGHLY SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
PROPOSED EXPANSION.
AND FOR HIM MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE EXISTING PROGRAM. TO PAY FOR
THE ENTIRE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING A CONFORMITY PACKAGE.
THE DOT SEVERAL CHANGES THAT
WILL MAKE TAX COMPLIANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION EASIER FOR
TAXPAYERS.
TAX REPAIRS OF THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD.
AS WELL AS A DOCTOR OTHER
CHANGES THAT MAKE GOOD POLICY
SENSE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ADOPTED
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO THE TAX
CODE THE CHANGE TO INDIVIDUALS
AND CORPORATIONS CALCULATE THEIR
TAX LIABILITY.
OUR PROPOSAL IS AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PERSONAL INCOME TAX.
AND CORPORATE TAX SYSTEMS ARE
INEVITABLY LINKED. TO THE
FEDERAL TAX SYSTEMS AND IN SOME
CASES CONFORMITY TO CERTAIN TAX
PROVISIONS IS NECESSARY FOR AN
EFFICIENT AND ADMINISTRATION OF
OUR TAX SYSTEM.
IN ADDITION THERE ARE SEVERAL
CHANGES ADOPTED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE GOOD POLICY
CENTS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ANOTHER POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS
THAT THIS IS NOT A TAX REFORM
PROPOSAL WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT
ITEMS THAT WILL EASY
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON
TAXPAYERS.
OR FOR PROVISIONS THAT MAKES
SENSE ON AN INDIVIDUAL BASIS OR
IN COMBINATION WITH ONE OR TWO
OTHER PROVISIONS.
WE'RE NOT LOOKING WITH THIS
PACKAGE TO BRING ABOUT
FUNDAMENTAL TAX REFORM.
SO I'D LIKE TO GO THROUGH AND
DESCRIBE THE VARIOUS ITEMS IN
OUR TAX CONFORMITY PACKAGE VERY
SADDAM'S ARE LISTED ON PAGE FOR
THE HEARING AGENDA --
AND AND THIS AND THIS IS THE
ADMINISTRATION CONFORMING
PROPOSAL.
THE FIRST ITEM.
IS A SMALL BUSINESS ACCOUNTING
REFORM CATION RULES UNDER
CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW.
WE ALLOW CERTAIN SMALL
BUSINESSES MORE FLEXIBILITY IN
THE CAL IN THE COUNTY RULES THAT
THE USE.
GENERALLY SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
ALLOWED TO USE RULES.
I DO NOT KEEP TRACK OF THE
TIMING OF INCOME AND DEDUCTIONS
AS PRECISELY AS LARGE LARGER
BUSINESSES MUST FEEL.
OKAY OUR RULES WERE THE SAME AS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT UNTIL THE
ADOPTED THE TAX CUTS AND JOBS
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
NOT LAW MADE MORE BUSINESSES
ELIGIBLE FOR THE SIMPLIFIED
RULES --
ESSENTIALLY.
ALL TAXPAYERS WITH HER TO SEE
TEN OR TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
NOW CONFORMING TO THOSE RULES
MANY SMALL BUSINESSES WILL BE
REQUIRED --
TO TO KEEP TWO SUCH BOOKS ONE
SET FOR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ONE
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE SECOND ITEM ON OUR LIST IS
REPEAL OF TECHNICAL TERMINATION
OF PARTNERSHIPS.
UNDER PRIOR LAW AND UNDER PRIOR
FEDERAL LONG CURRENT STATE LAW.
IF A PARTNERSHIP AS A TRANSFER
OF MORE THAN 50%.
OF THE TOTAL INTEREST IN
PARTNERSHIP CAPITAL PROFITS
WITHIN A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD.
THE PARTNERSHIP IS CONSIDERED TO
BE TECHNICALLY TERMINATED EVEN
IF THE PARTNERSHIP THE THE
ACTIVITY OF THE BUSINESS
CONTINUES.
WHAT THIS MEANS IT CAUSES A
SEVERAL ATTACKS?
EVENTS --
AND SO.
IF WE IF IF WE STILL HAVE
TECHNICAL TERMINATION AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES NOT THAT
AGAIN IS GOING TO CAUSE
TAXPAYERS TO KEEP TWO SETS OF
BOOKS -- ONE
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ONE
FOR THE STATE.
THE THIRD ITEM --
NOW WITH THAT WE WOULD STILL
WITH THE WEED CONFORM TO IS A
LIMITATION ON A LIKE KIND
EXCHANGE IS.
UNDER PRIOR FEDERALLY KERN ST
LOS CERTAIN TYPES OF REAL OR
PERSONAL PROPERTY ARE SOLD.
THE GAIN ON THE SALE OF THAT
ASSET IS DEFERRED FOR TAX
PURPOSES.
IF IT IS EXCHANGE FOR LIKE KIND
US.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT UNDER THE
TAX CUTS AND JOBS ACT A
RESTRICTED THE USE OF LIKEN
EXCHANGES. TO THOSE DEFERRALS TO
ONLY REAL PROPERTY AND WE WE
WERE PROPOSING TO CAN TO CONFORM
TO THAT SAME PROVISION.
THE FOURTH ITEM PERTAINS TO
EMPLOYEE FRINGE BENEFITS THAT
ARE PROVIDED BY BUSINESSES BUT
ARE NOT TAX TO THE EMPLOYEE.
THE FEDERAL TAX LAW LIMITED THE
ABILITY OF BUSINESSES TO DETECT
THESE TYPE OF EXPENSES.
OF PERTAINING TO SEE TO CERTAIN
MEALS AND ENTERTAINMENT AND TO
TRANSPORTATION BENEFITS.
THE FIFTH AUTUMN MARLYS IS
CHANGING THE DEDUCTIBILITY OF
EXCESSIVE COMPENSATION --
TO TALKING PLEASE BY PUBLIC
CORPORATIONS. FOR PRIOR FEDERAL
IN CURRENT STATE LAW.
PAYMENTS ARE MADE TO CERTAIN TOP
EMPLOYEES THAT EXCEEDED MILLION
DOLLARS.
COULD NOT BE DEDUCTED BY THE
EMPLOYER AND THAT EXCLUDED --
PAYMENTS MADE THROUGH IMPROVE
PERFORMANCE BASED OF OF
CONTRACTS.
THE FEDERAL BILL LIMITED THE
EXCEPTION IMAGE BASED PAYMENTS
AND EXPANDED THE NUMBER OF
COVERED --
EMPLOYEES FROM FORTY FIVE WE
WOULD WE WOULD --
WE PROPOSE CONFORM TO THOSE THAT
PROVISION.
THE SIXTH AND SEVENTH ITEM
SUPPLIED ABLE ACCOUNTS.
ABEL ACCOUNTS WERE CHEATING A
BETTER LIFE EXPERIENCE ACCOUNTS.
WERE PERMITTED BY FEDERAL LAW IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN IS A TAX
ADVANTAGED SAVINGS ACCOUNT. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES.
CALIFORNIA CONFORM TO THE ABLE
COUNT.
THE THE TAX ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN THE FEDERAL TAX SECOND.
TWO SEVEN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EXPANDED THESE ACCOUNTS.
A BY ALLOWING BENEFICIARIES TO
CONTRIBUTE UP TO THE POVERTY
LEVEL ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. TO ENABLE ACCOUNT.
IN ADDITION THE FEDERAL LAW
ALLOWED FIVE TWENTY NINE COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS TO BE ROLLED
OVER INTO ABLE ACCOUNTS --
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE KEEP.
OF RULES FOR QUALIFIED SAVINGS
ACCOUNT THE SAME SO THAT A
TAXPAYER DOESN'T END UP HAVING A
DISQUALIFIED CALIFORNIA ACCOUNT.
JUST BECAUSE THE FOLLOWING
FEDERAL RULES.
THE EIGHTH ITEM WOULD LIMIT THE
ABILITY OF INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS
TO USE BUSINESS LOSSES TO OFFSET
NON BUSINESS INCOME.
THE TAX CUTS AND JOBS ACT ONLY
ALLOWS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF BUSINESS
LOSSES OR FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR MARRIED TAXPAYERS.
TO BE USED AS AN OFFSET AGAINST
NON BUSINESS INCOME.
SUCH AS WAGES INTEREST DIVIDENDS
AND CAPITAL GAINS.
LOSSES ABOVE THE 200-500-00500
THOUSAND DOLLAR THRESHOLD CAN BE
USED TO OFFSET INCOME IN
SUBSEQUENT YEARS.
THIS PROVISION IS A GOOD POLICY
BECAUSE PROVIDES TAXPAYERS FROM
FROM USING LOSSES THAT ARE
SOMETIMES JUST PAPER LOSSES. TO
OFFSET ACTUAL INCOME.
AND I THOUGHT ITEM IS A
LIMITATION ON THE DIRECTION OF
FTA SEE PREMIUMS.
FTA SEEP FTA SHE PREMIUMS WHICH
ARE PREMIUMS PAID BY BANKS TO
INSURE DEPOSITS ARE GENERALLY
DEDUCTIBLE.
THE FEDERAL TAX THE NEW FEDERAL
TAX LAW CHANGE THAT SO THAT --
FOR LARGE BANKS THOSE WITHOUT
SUCH OVER FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DEDUCT
THEIR FTA SEE PREMIUMS.
AND FOR THOSE WITH A FOR BANKS
WITH ASSETS BETWEEN TEN BILLION
IN FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS.
THEIR THEIR OF THEIR ABILITY
SINCE HIS FACE OUT OVER THAT
RANGE.
THE TENTH ITEM IS THE
ELIMINATION OF A OF A SEPARATE
SECTION THREE THIRTY EIGHT
ELECTION.
SECTION THREE THIRTY EIGHT WAS
ENACTED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
TO ALLOW TAXPAYER THE PURCHASES
HE CORPORATION. TO TREAT A
PORTRAIT OF A PURCHASE OF THE
CORPORATION STOCK AS A PURCHASE
INSTEAD OF THE ASSETS OF THE
CORPORATION.
THIS SELECTION CAN HAVE TAX
CONSEQUENCES BECAUSE STOCK SALES
MAY BE ASSIGNED TO STATES IN A
DIFFERENT WAY THAN THEMSELVES OF
ASSETS ARE SIGNED.
BY ALLOWING SECTION THREE A
SEPARATE SECTION THREE THIRTY
ELECTION FOR STATE PURPOSES.
THAT DIFFERS FROM THE FEDERAL
ELECTION HE CREATES A
POSSIBILITY UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR INCOME TO BE
VOID BEING TAXED BY ANY STATE.
WE PROPOSE REQUIRING TAXPAYERS
TO MAKE THE SAME ELECTION FOR
CALIFORNIA THAT THEY MAKE FOR
FEDERAL PURPOSES.
THE ELEVENTH ITEMS OPPORTUNITIES
OWN SOME TAKE A LITTLE MORE TIME
TO GO INTO THIS IS A LOW OF AND
BECAUSE MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT
ABOUT THIS.
SO JUST TO GIVE YOU SOME
BACKGROUND TAX CUTS AND JOBS ACT
CREATED OPPORTUNITIES OWNS.
ALL STATES WERE ALLOWED TO
DESIGNATE OPPORTUNITIESOWNS IN
CERTAIN ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED AREAS WITHIN THE
STATE.
CALIFORNIA PARTICIPATED IN THE
PROCESS.
AND LAST SPRING WE DESIGNATED
EIGHT HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITIES OWNS IS
ENCOURAGED --
BY SEVERAL FEDERAL TAX
INCENTIVES.
THE FIRST INCENTIVE.
IS A TEMPORARY DEFERRAL OF ANY
CAPITAL --
IF THOSE GAINS ARE INVESTED IN
OPPORTUNITIES AND FUND --
AND OF IF IF IF THEY'RE INVESTED
IN OPPORTUNITIES ON FUND WITHIN
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS OF THE OF
THE SALE OF THE OF THE ASSET.
ALL OF THE DEFERRED GAINS MUST
BE REALIZED I'M SORRY IF THE
GAMES ARE HELD FOR SEVEN YEARS --
THERE HELD FOR FIVE YEARS A
TAXPAYER ALSO RECEIVES A 10%
EXEMPTION WHEN THE GAME IS
FINALLY --
TAXABLE AND THE GAME ITSELF FOR
SEVEN YEARS THE TAXPAYER WOULD
RECEIVE A 15% EXEMPTION WHEN THE
GAIN IS HAS FINALLY TAXABLE.
IN ADDITION --
HELLO AND AND ALL ALL THE GAMES
MUST BE REALIZE.
BY THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY SIX
IN ADDITION ANY GAMES THAT ARE
THE EARNED --
BY THOSE INVESTMENTS IN THE
OPPORTUNITIES OWN FUND ARE TAX
FREE IF THEY'RE HELD FOR TEN
YEARS OR MORE.
WE ARE PROPOSING TO CONFORM TO
THESE AND TAX INCENTIVES FOR
INVESTMENT AND OPPORTUNITIES AND
FUND.
THAT ARE DIRECTED PROJECTS THAT
ARE BOTH WITHIN A CALIFORNIA
OPPORTUNITIES OWN.
AND ARE A QUALIFY TYPE OF
INVESTMENT.
AND A QUALIFIED TO INVESTMENT
WOULD BE WHAT AND INVESTMENT IN.
LOW INCOME HOUSING CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY OR GREEN JOBS.
BECAUSE OF THE GENEROUS FEDERAL
TAX BREAKS IT SEEMS VERY LIKELY
THAT INVESTMENT DOLLARS WILL BE
FLOWING IN TOP PURSUIT
OPPORTUNITY ZONES ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES.
THE PURPOSE FOR PROPOSED
CONFORMITY IS TO PROVIDE AN
INCENTIVE FOR INVESTORS TO
INVEST THOSE OPPORTUNITIES OWN.
DOLLARS INTO CALIFORNIA
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS AND PROVIDE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BENEFITS TO
CALIFORNIANS.
AND WE HAVE AND WE WANT TO DO IT
IN A WAY THAT ENCOURAGES THE
RIGHT TYPE OF INVESTMENT THAT
ACTUALLY DOES BENEFIT CALIFORNIA.
AND THE CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE
AND WORK IN ECONOMIC AREAS.
SO MOVE ON TO ITEM --
TWELVE WHICH IS THE ELIMINATION
OF NET OPERATING LOSS CARRY
BACKS.
GENERALLY WHEN A TEXTURE HAS A
HAS A LOSS.
IN ONE YEAR THEY CAN USE THAT
LOST OFFSET GAINS IN OTHER YEARS
UNDER --
PRIOR FEDERAL LAW AND CURRENT
STATE LAW.
TEXTURES WERE ALLOWED TO CARRY
BACK.
HE LOST A TWO YEARS TO TWO MEN
PRIOR YEAR RETURNS AND USE THOSE
LOSSES TO OFFSET INCOME IN THOSE
YEARS -- AND
ALTERNATIVELY --
OR HELP THE ELDERLY THEY COULD
CARRY THOSE LOSSES FORD FOR
TWENTY YEARS AND OFFSET INCOME
IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS --
THAT IS UNTIL THE THE LOSSES
HAVE BEEN USED UP OFFSETTING
GAINS INCOME.
THE NEW FEDERAL LAW ELIMINATES
THE ABILITY TO CARRY BACK LOSSES.
AND IT --
AND IT LIMITS THE USE OF NET
OPERATING LOSS CARRY FORWARDS.
SO THAT THEY CAN ALSO NO MORE
THAN 80% OF THE CURRENT INCOME
AND ANYONE IN ANY ONE YEAR.
THE FEDERAL LAW CHANGE ALSO
REPLACE THE TWENTY YEAR CARRY
FOR LIMIT WITH AN UNLIMITED
CARRY FORWARD PERIOD.
WE ARE PROPOSING CONFORMITY JUST
TO THE LOS KERRY BACK PROVISION
TO THE ELIMINATION OF LOS KERRY
BACK PROVISION.
THE FINAL ITEM ON OUR LIST
RELATES TO THE TREATMENT OF
STUDENT LOANS DISCHARGED ON
ACCOUNT OF DISABILITY OR DEATH.
GENERALLY FORGIVENESS OF A LOAN
IS TREATED AS INCOME TO THE TRIP
TO THE PERSON WHO'S DEBT IS
FORGIVEN.
UNDER THE NEW FEDERAL LAW ANY
STUDENT DEBT THAT IS FORGIVEN ON
ACCOUNT OF DISABILITY OR DEATH.
IS NOT CONSIDERED INCOME.
WE PROPOSED TO CONFORM TO
CONFORM TO THIS TREATMENT.
SO JUST A COUPLE CONCLUDING
STATEMENTS IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ESTIMATED REVENUE IMPACT.
ON ON PAGE FOR YOU KNOW NEWS
OVER ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION IN.
A NINETEEN TWENTY AND AND ALMOST
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THESE
ESTIMATES ARE STILL JUST
ESTIMATES WE WERE ARE STILL WORK
WITH FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO MAKE
SURE THE ESTIMATES ARE
REASONABLE REFER REFLECTION OF
WHAT WE CAN EXPECT OF FROM
CONFORMITY WITH THE FOR THESE
IN THE WAY THAT WE ARE
CONFORMING TO THESE ITEMS.
ARE THE FINAL NUMBERS MAY BE
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT OF WHAT WE
SHOW HERE.
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE SUFFICIENT REVENUE TO PAY
FOR THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM SO THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN
BUDGET RESILIENCY.
FINALLY --
JUST ABOUT LANGUAGE AND WE
UNFORTUNATELY DO NOT HAVE ANY.
POSTED YET BUT WE WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH LET'S COUNCIL --
TO TO GET THAT DRAFTED HIM AND
WE HOPE TO HAVE.
ORANGE POSTED SOON AND I AND I
HOPE TO HAVE EVERYTHING --
AVAILABLE BY EARLY APRIL.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND
HAPPY TO HELP YOU QUICKLY IT WAS
BURKE.
SO I HAVE A QUESTION ON THE
ESTIMATED NEXT NET CHANGE IN
REVENUE IT STARTS AT ONE POINT
SEVEN BUT THAT IT GOES DOWN TO
ONE POINT FOUR I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS WHY THE REDUCTION IN
THE SECOND QUESTION IS DOES THAT
CONTINUE TO REDUCE --
THE REDUCTION IS GENERALLY
BECAUSE WHEN WE CAN FOR
CONFORMING.
AS A ONE ONE NINETEEN AND AND
BUT WORKING FOR ME AT THE END OF
EIGHTEEN NINETY SO NONE OF THE
NONE OF THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN REVENUE CAN SHOW OPEN
TO IN.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IT'S ALL GONNA
SHOW FOR NINETEEN TWENTIES OF
CENTURY NINETY TWENTY EFFECTS OF
DOUBLING UP OKAY SO I'M NOT
SAYING THAT WOULD STAY
IDENTICALLY AT ONE POINT FOUR
THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT
CHANGE OVER TIME BUT WE
GENERALLY EXPECT THE NUMBER TO
BE AROUND ONE POINT FOUR LIVING.
COMING OUT [inaudible]
LL.
OKAY HI JUSTIN GROSSI LA --
I'M GONNA TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT THE
E. H. PROPOSED THE EIGHTIES AND
WEATHER FOR IS GONNA TALK ABOUT
CONFORMITY.
K. ON THE E. I. T. C. EXPANSION
FIRST YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
SORT OF THE BENEFITS AND YOU
KNOW WHO'S GOING TO BENEFIT AND
HOW MUCH.
SO IF YOU WOULD TURN TO PAGE TWO
OF THE HEARING AGENDA.
THERE IS A LINE GRAPH THAT YOU
KNOW SHOWS HOW MUCH PEOPLE WERE
HOW MUCH THAT.
FILERS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
EIGHTY SI YOU'RE GOING TO GET IT
EACH INCOME LEVEL.
SO IF YOU SEE ARM WELL FIRST OF
ALL EACH AS IT THE GRAPH SHOWS
EVERY FILER WITH AT LEAST ONE
DEPENDENT UNDER AGE.
SIX IS GOING TO GET FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS AS LONG AS YOU HAVE AT
LEAST ONE DOLLAR OF EARNED
INCOME.
IF YOUR INCOME IS IN THE RANGE
BETWEEN TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IT PHASES OUT TO AVOID A
CLIFF AT THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS --
THIS THE MORE COMPLICATED PIECE
OF THE PROPOSED EXPANSION IF YOU
NOTICE --
THE PHASE OUT RANGE OF THE E. I.
T. C. OVER WHICH YOUR E. I. T.
C. M..
ABOUT DECLINES AS THEIR INCOME
RISES NOTICE THERE'S A KINK IN
IT.
SO UNDER CURRENT LAW. FOR FILER
WITH TWO DEPENDENTS THAT KINK
COMES AT ABOUT FOURTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF INCOME.
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL --
PEOPLE WHOSE INCOME IS YOU'RE
JUST BELOW THE KINK --
TO YOU KNOW IF A FAIR AMOUNT
ABOVE IT WILL GET THE BIGGEST
BENEFITS.
BUT IF YOUR INCOME IF YOUR
CURRENT.
INCOME IS TOO FAR BELOW THE KINK
AMOUNT YOU DON'T GET A BENEFIT
FROM THIS PROPOSAL UNLESS YOU
HAVE IT AT LEAST ONE DEPENDENT
UNDER THE AGE OF SIX NOW THIS
CRAFT SHOWS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
IF YOU HAVE TO DEPENDENCE.
IF YOU HAVE ONE DEPENDENT THAT
KING COMES IN ABOUT TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF INCOME SO PEOPLE YEAH
WITH INCOME FROM ROUGHLY TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO A LITTLE
MORE WILL SEE THE BIGGEST
BENEFITS.
IF YOU HAVE NO DEPENDENTS THAT
KING COMES BETWEEN FIVE THOUSAND
AND SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
INCOME.
BUT THE AMOUNTS THAT YOU GET IF
YOU HAVE NO DEPENDENTS ARE VERY
SMALL TO BEGIN WITH AND SO THE
THE BENNETT THE INCREASE YOU
WOULD GET FROM THIS EXPANSION IS
ALSO FAIRLY SMALL.
OKAY -- I
LIKE TO TURN TO THE CRITERIA
THAT OUR OFFICE USES TO EVALUATE
YEAH I SEE PURPLE YEAH A T. C.
PROPOSALS.
FIRST OF ALL WE LOOK AT THE WE
THE EFFECT THAT WE THINK THE
PROPOSAL HAVE ON POVERTY IN THE
STATE. FOR ANY EIGHTY SEE
EXPANSION OF ANY GIVEN SIZE
THERE'S A TRADE OFF BETWEEN HOW
MANY PEOPLE YOU CAN REACH AND
HOW MUCH HELP YOU CAN GET GIVE
THE EACH A BENEFICIARY.
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL TENDS
TO GO AS OPPOSED TO GOING DEEP
BECAUSE IT IT REACHES A LOT OF
PEOPLE WITH INCOME BELOW THE
POVERTY LEVEL OR NOT MUCH ABOVE
IT.
BUT IT DOESN'T GIVE THEM MAKE A
HUGE AMOUNT --
AND IT ALSO IF YOU LOOK AT THE
IF YOU LOOK AT THE LINE GRAPH
AGAIN IT DOESN'T GIVE A WHOLE
LOT TO PEOPLE WHOSE INCOME.
UP BACK UP IT DOESN'T GIVE A
WHOLE LOT TO THE THE ELIGIBLE
FILERS WITH THE LOWEST INCOMES
IT GIVES MORE TO THE PEOPLE SORT
OF AT THE UPPER END OF THE
ELIGIBLE.
RANGE.
SEC THE SECOND THING WE LOOK AT
IS THE PROPOSALS AFFECT ON WORK
FORCE PARTICIPATION.
NOW THE EVIDENCE SUGGESTS THAT
THE EITC.
HAS A FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
IN TERMS OF INDUCING PEOPLE TO
JOIN THE WORK FORCE.
HOWEVER IT DOESN'T APPEAR TO
HAVE A BIG IMPACT ON THE HOURS
WORKED OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ALREADY
IN THE WORK FORCE.
AND SO THIS PROPOSAL WE EXPECT
WOULD PROBABLY NOT HAVE A MAJOR
IMPACT ON OF PEOPLE'S WORK
PARTICIPATION.
MOSTLY BECAUSE IT CONCENTRATES
THE BENEFIT TOWARD THE TAIL END
OF THE ELIGIBLE INCOME RANGE FOR
THE EFFECT ON PEOPLE'S WORK
HOURS IS GENERALLY SMALLER.
OKAY FINALLY OUR OUR ROUTE
REPORT THAT WE PUT OUT A FEW
DAYS AGO.
SUGGEST SOME POTENTIAL
ALTERNATIVES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD PURSUE.
IF THEY WERE MORE INTERESTED IN
TARGETING THE IN TOWARD --
RELIEVING DEEP POVERTY OR TOWARD
ENCOURAGING WORK WE ALSO
DISCUSSED SOME POSSIBILITIES FOR
PROVIDING THE CREDIT ON A
MONTHLY BASIS TO RECIPIENTS.
AND WE'D BE HAPPY.
TO TAKE QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT IF
YOU'RE INTERESTED.
THANK YOU MISS BURKE.
I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS --
ONE AND AND I THINK.
ON THE WORK WE DO ON POVERTY
OBVIOUSLY AT THE HOPE IS THAT IT
COMES OUT ON A MONTHLY BASIS I
THINK OUR STE OUR STUDY HAS
SHOWN THAT THAT IS A BETTER
OPTION HOWEVER I AM CURIOUS.
ABOUT HOW MUCH WHEN YOU SAY THAT
THERE IS THAT IT'S NOT THAT THE
ITC IS NOT ENCOURAGING
NECESSARILY THE GROWTH OF OUR IS
HOW MUCH OF THAT IS AN ACTUAL
RESULT THAT YOU BELIEVE OF THE
ACTUAL CREDIT VERSES.
THE THRESHOLD IN WHICH PEOPLE IT
HIT A CERTAIN THRESHOLD AND THEN
THE OTHER SERVICES ARE
INTERRUPTED.
OKAY WHAT AT THE NEXUS OF THAT
YEAH THERE IS THERE ONE OF THE
CONCERNS PEOPLE HAVE WITH THE I.
T. C. IS YOU BECAUSE THE BENEFIT
PHASES OUT AS PEOPLE'S INCOME
RISES OVER THAT.
PHASE OUT RANGE THAT ALSO
COINCIDES WITH THEM AS YOU SAID.
A NUMBER OF OTHER PROGRAMS THE
THE THE BENEFITS FROM THOSE
TAPER OFF OF YOUR INCOME RISES
TO AND SO THAT'S THAT'S YOU THAT
IS A CONCERN YOU HAVE WITH THE
E. I. T. C..
IN PRACTICE THOUGH THE THE
MARGIN THAT TENDS TO MATTER MOST
IS FOR ANY GIVEN WORKER --
BASICALLY THE AMOUNT OF AFTER
TAX INCOME.
THEY WOULD GET FROM WORKING SAY
TWENTY HOURS A WEEK AS OPPOSED.
TO FORTY BECAUSE THAT'S SUCH A
PRETTY YOU KNOW.
A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT DISCREET
JOB FOR MOST PEOPLE AS IT TURNS
OUT.
THE THE EFFECTIVE TAX RATES THEY
FACE WHEN YOU COMBINE BOTH THE
A. T. C. ANOTHER MEANS TESTED
PROGRAMS.
IT TENDS NOT TO BE ENOUGH TO
HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON WORK
EFFORT I MEAN.
PEOPLE'S.
PEOPLE'S WORKFORCE PARTICIPATION
ESPECIALLY AMONG SECOND EARNERS
IN THE HOUSEHOLD IS YELLS IT IS
SENSITIVE TO THE THE CHANGE IN
THE EFFECTIVE TAX RATE THE FACE
BUT NO BECAUSE USE THIS IS STILL
YOUR RETAINING GIVES.
A SIGNIFICANT CHUNK OF THE X.
FOR PRE TAX EARNINGS THEY FIND
THAT THE IMPACT ON THE HOURS
THAT PEOPLE WORK IS ACTUALLY NOT
THAT HIGH IN SO [inaudible]
THE ANOTHER WAY TO THINK ABOUT
THAT IS SORT OF THE WORRIES THAT
PEOPLE HAVE ABOUT THE EITC
DISCOURAGING WORK IN THE PHASE
OUT RANGE --
IT TURNS OUT NOT TO ACTUALLY BE
THAT BAD IN THOSE TERMS
[inaudible]
THIS WEEK'S.
I'M.
SORRY THOSE ALLOWED --
I'M A BIG SUPPORTER OF THE I. T.
C. -- I
THINK IT'S ONE WAY WE CAN DEAL
WITH THE CHI RISING INCOME
INEQUALITY ESPECIALLY WITH THE
COST OF HOUSING.
IN FACT I THINK WE SHOULD EXPAND
UTC TO INCLUDE --
UNPAID --
CARE GIVERS --
ANYONE IS A CARE GIVER KNOWS HOW
HARD THAT WORK IS --
BUT ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I HAD
FOR YOU ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS MY UNDERSTANDING OF
THIS --
PROPOSAL DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
TAXPAYERS THAT NUMBERS TO CLAIM
BENEFITS --
AND WITHOUT THIS ABOUT ONE POINT
ONE MILLION FAMILIES AND WILL
NOT BE ABLE --
TO TO CLAIM THAT CREDIT WHICH I
VIEW THIS AS AN ISSUE OF YOU
KNOW FAIRNESS AND EQUITY.
A WHAT'S THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
THIS -- SO
YEAH I I'VE BEEN TO IT WAS NOT
AN ORIGINAL PROPOSAL WE WE'VE --
WE'VE HEARD FROM ADVOCATES AND
AND THAT SORT SO IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
FEASIBILITY OF DOING I MEAN IT
IS NOT.
AS STRAIGHTFORWARD AS AS AS
PRIDE IN EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT TO TAXPAYERS WITH WITH SO
SECURITY NUMBERS BUT SOMETHING
WE'RE LOOKING INTO --
BUT IT WOULD HAVE TO FIT WITHIN
THE THE BUDGETARY FRAMEWORK.
A QUESTION ON WHAT OUTCOMES FOR
LOW INCOME WORKING FAMILIES DO
YOU EXPECT TO SEE.
THIS PROPOSED EXPANSION OF CAL
U. ET I SEE.
I'M SORRY WHAT TO WHAT WHAT
OUTCOMES FOR LOW INCOME WORKING
FAMILIES DO YOU EXPECT TO SEE
FROM PROPOSAL.
PROPOSED EXPANSION WELL I DON'T
THE ITC YEAH WHAT WHAT WE ARE
WHAT -- WHAT
WE EXPECT TO SEE IS THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE MORE FAMILIES
GETTING MORE DOLLARS TO HELP
THEM?
DEAL WITH.
UP FINANCIAL STRESS. TO ALMOST
DOUBLING THE AMOUNT --
WE WERE BE A MORE THAN DOUBLING
THE NOW THIS IS GO FOR SEVENTEEN
TO THIRTY RIGHT. THIRTY MILLION
OLD I'M SORRY THAT THE THE
MAXIMUM INCORRECT YES YES YES
RIGHT EXACTLY YEAH FOR FOR FOR A
HOUSEHOLD WITH NO DEPENDENTS
HAMMY FOLKS DO YOU THINK THEY'LL
LET HOW MANY MORE FAMILIES WILL
LET IN.
THAT -- THAT
IS EXPECTED --
BOTH FAMILIES WITH --
TEXTURES WITH DEPENDENTS AND
WITHOUT TO MANAGE IT SHOULD
BRING IN ABOUT ANOTHER MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS [inaudible]
MR.
TO A COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS I
WILL FOLLOW UP ON WHAT.
MISS WICKS JUST ASKED AROUND I
TO NUMBER SO.
IS THERE ANY REAL JUSTIFICATION
FOR NOT INCLUDING ALL TAX FILERS --
YOU SORT OF ALLUDED TO THE FACT
THAT THERE MIGHT BE A DIFFERENCE
AND I WANTED TO UNDERSTAND FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
WHAT THE REAL DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN SOMEONE WHO FILES WITH
AN AYE TEN VERSES SO SECURITY
NUMBER?
ON I I DON'T KNOW THAT I CAN.
DRESS THAT COMPLETELY --
I I THINK I THINK GENERAL THE
EITC WE'VE BEEN --
IT'S BEEN A SUBSET OF THE OF THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM.
AND AND TEXTURES WITH AYE TENS
AND ALLOWED THE HC AND FEDERAL
PROGRAM.
LAST YEAR WE WE DID MAKE A BREAK
FROM THE FEDERAL PROGRAM THAT WE
ALLOWED IT --
TO TAXPAYERS OVER --
SIXTY FIVE IN AND UNDER --
UNDER TWENTY FIVE WITHOUT
DEPENDENT SO WE HAVE WE HAVE
MADE THAT THAT BREAK BUT I'D SAY
GENERALLY THE THE STARTING POINT
IS.
YOU WERE WE WOULD LIKE TO KEEP
IT CONSISTS WITH FEDERAL PROGRAM
BECAUSE IT MAKES IT EASIER TO
ADMINISTER --
AND AND BUT I I I DON'T KNOW
THAT I CAN.
I'VE I HAVEN'T I DON'T HAVE A
GOOD ANSWERS TO WHAT SORT OF
HURDLES THERE MAY BE --
TO TO PROVIDING --
AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE
LOOKING INTO WHO TOOK.
GREAT IF WE COULD GET SOME
ANALYSIS ABOUT IT SEEMS TO ME AS
MS WOODS SAID --
THAT THE IDEA THAT ONE CATEGORY
WOULD RECEIVE THIS IN ANOTHER
CATEGORY WOULDN'T DOESN'T FEEL
FAIR DOESN'T FEEL EQUITABLE.
HAVE TO BE DOES COLLECT TAXES
FROM PEOPLE WITH AYE TENNIS BUT
YOU'RE SAYING THAT WE CAN'T GIVE
REFUNDS TO THOSE SAME FILERS.
THAT'S WELL I AND AND I THE
OTHER THING TO KEEP IN MIND THAT
THERE IS A BUDGETARY CONSTRAINTS
SO WE CAN'T.
AND AND I THINK WE DO HAVE AN S.
WITH THE DOLLARS TO PROVIDE. TO
FIGHT THE ATC TO TAXPAYERS WITH
TITANS.
IT SO BUT WHAT I'M HERE AND IT'S
A ADMINISTRATIVE THERE'S NOT A
THERE'S NOT AT TAX EQUITY REASON
THAT I YEAH I I I I I I I CAN'T
THINK OF A TAX EQUITY REASON.
MORE BUDGETARY AND AND
ADMINISTRATIVE --
COULD I SHOULD THE CONVERSATION --
TO THE PEOPLE'S AROUND
IMPLEMENTING MONTHLY PAYMENTS --
COULD YOU GIVE US A SENSE OF
WHAT IF TO BE HAS SAID AS FAR AS
WHAT TYPE OF ISSUES WOULD NEED
TO BE FIGURED OUT TO IMPLEMENT.
MONTHLY DISBURSEMENT --
HOW LONG WOULD THAT TAKE WHAT'S
A REALISTIC TIME FRAME FOR FOR
DOING THAT?
YEAH WE WE ARE STILL EARLY IN
THE PROCESS OF OF DETERMINING
HOW THAT HOW THAT WOULD WORK --
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THE PROBLEM
WITH WITH AN ADMINISTRATION
MONTHLY PAYMENTS IN ADVANCE.
IS THAT --
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH.
EITC HOUSEHOLD IS GOING TO EARN
HER IS GOING TO HE'S GOING TO
EARN -- AND
YOU.
WON A SECOND JOB AT THE END OF
THE YEAR THAT BRINGS IN A COUPLE
THOUSAND DOLLARS COULD CHANGE RE
H. C. DRAMATICALLY BECAUSE WE'VE
GOT -- YOU
KNOW THE FEDERAL THE FEDERAL TAX
THE EIGHTY SI HAS MORE OF A IF
YOU KNOW IT IT INCREASES FOR ALL
THAT IT PLATEAUS AND THEN IT
DROPS OFF.
AND SO THERE LOOK. FOR THAT
PROGRAM IS A LITTLE MORE --
WILL YOU NOT SO SUSCEPTIBLE TO
HAVING SMALL CHANGES IN INCOME
DROPPED DRAMATICALLY CHANGE HE
EIGHTY SO THAT SO THERE'S
THERE'S A PROBLEM.
SO I'LL JUST SAY THAT'S A
PROBLEM THAT WERE THAT WERE
TRYING TO SEE HOW WE CAN
OVERCOME THAT --
WAYS THAT WE CAN BECAUSE THAT IS
CERTAINLY SOME THE GOVERNOR HAS --
HAS HAS.
SAID THAT HE WOULD LIKE TO DO
THAT THAT WE'RE WE'RE GOING AND
WE ARE EXPLORING WAYS TO DO THAT.
BUT AT THIS POINT.
HI I AM THAT SAID THERE IS TO
SEE HE CONCEPTUALLY A PROBLEM
WITH KNOWING BEFORE HAND HOW
MUCH EARNED INCOME TAX READ.
TEXTURES GOING TO EARN AND WE DO
KNOW THAT PEOPLE TEND TO MOVE IN
AND OUT OF THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT --
FAIRLY DRAMATICALLY FROM YEAR TO
YEAR SO THEY DON'T AND IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE THE SAME
EXACT EXACT SAME PEOPLE.
GETTING THE HC CHEERS SO YOU
CAN'T JUST RELY ON WHAT THEY GOT
LAST YEAR --
FOR WHAT THEY'LL GET TAX YEAR
OKAY --
THIRD TOPIC --
I WAS CONSIDERING THIS YOU'RE
MOVING THE BILL FOR AROUND THE
TOPIC OF AUTOMATIC FILING AND I
WANTED TO GET A SENSE.
I KNOW IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS CALIFORNIA HAD A READY
RETURN PROGRAM.
AND WONDERING HAS THERE BEEN A
CONVERSATION ABOUT REVIVING THAT
MODEL FOR THE EIGHTIES SEE
ELIGIBLE HOUSEHOLDS --
I'M THERE THERE ISN'T THERE'S
NOT BEEN A CONVERSATION AS YET.
CERTAINLY THAT'S SOMETHING WE
COULD LOOK INTO IF THIRTY
SOMETHING YEAR --
LOVE TO GETS MORE EDUCATION OKAY
YEP TO GET MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THAT AND WE CAN COLLEAGUES
WHAT WHAT THAT REALLY ADDRESSES
THE FACT THAT.
THERE ARE MANY INDIVIDUALS WHO
DO NOT OWE TAXES YOU DON'T HAVE
A REASON A FILE BUT THUS THEY
DON'T GET THE REFUNDABLE CREDIT
SO THE IDEA IS HOW DO WE CAPTURE
THAT GROUP OF FOLKS --
LESSER QUESTIONS I HAVE --
AND I WOULD PROPOSES TO EITHER
NOW THE ADMINISTRATION OR TO THE
LA -- IS --
WE TALKED ABOUT --
THERE WAS SOME DISCUSSION TO
HOUSEHOLDS WITH.
KIDS I'M WONDERING HAS THERE
BEEN ANALYSIS OF HOW THIS CREDIT
WOULD AFFECT CHILDREN IN DEEP
POVERTY.
THERE'S A LOT OF INTEREST AND
CHAIRWOMAN OF OUR PROTECT HIM
HE'S BEEN LEADING ON THAT AND I
THINK MANY OF US ARE INTERESTED
IN WHAT THAT IMPACT WOULD BE --
THE MULTIPLIER EFFECTS HOW WE
CAN JUSTIFY THIS --
I MEAN I I I I CAN'T I CAN'T
TELL YOU THAT I'VE DONE A OF AN
ANALYSIS OF THAT OTHER THAN THAT
IT WOULD IT CERTAINLY WOULD
PROVIDE --
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS WHICH WOULD
BE SIGNIFICANT HELP TO THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS DO WE KNOW FOR LA --
HAVE YOU DONE ANY ADDITIONAL
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS OF WHAT THAT
WOULD LOOK LIKE.
BUT WE HAVEN'T TRIED TO DO ANY
SORT OF MODEL LIKE HOW MIGHT
THAT IT.
THAT MIGHT AFFECT THE ECONOMY IN
OTHER WAYS OR HOW WOULD YOU KNOW.
WHAT AFFECT OTHER OUTCOMES FOR
THEM BUT WE HAVE SORT OF RUN
ESTIMATES OF HOW MANY PEOPLE IN
DEEP POVERTY READ BE AFFECTED BY --
THE ADMINISTRATION'S FOR
PROPOSAL AND BY SOME OF THE
ALTERNATIVES WE TALKED ABOUT.
TO COULD YOU GET THAT
INFORMATION TO US.
I WOULD NEED MORE OF A SPECIFIC
A QUESTION LIKE --
WHAT SPECIFICALLY YOU WANT US TO
ESTIMATE --
TRY TO LOOK INTO IF YOU SAID YOU
RAN SOME MODELS ON THE IMPACT OF
THIS --
ANOTHER FAMILIES AND THE POVERTY
YEAH WE DID --
IN OUR REPORT WE TALK ABOUT THE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE --
WHO WOULD BE MOVED OUT OF
POVERTY OR OUT OF DEEP POVERTY --
UNDER THE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND UNDER OF ONE OF OUR
ALTERNATIVES.
OKAY.
AND THE FINAL QUESTION HAS THERE
BEEN ANY ANALYSIS OF HOW MANY
CARE GIVERS OF ADULTS COULD BE
ELIGIBLE IF WE EXTENDED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CARE FOR
DEPENDENT ELDERLY FOR ADULT
FAMILY MEMBERS SO THE IDEA OF
NOT JUST IN CARE KIDS TO TAKE
CARE OF SENIORS.
GIVEN THE SILVER SYNONYME GIVEN
WHAT WE KNOW OF THE NUMBERS THAT
ARE COMING UP AND HOW
CHALLENGING THE SITUATION IS FOR
FAMILIES --
I BUT I BELIEVE THAT IT'S I
BELIEVE THAT SOME POINT I'VE
I'VE ASKED A QUESTION I BUT I
DON'T I DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER
RIGHT NOW BUT I CAN GET BACK TO
YOU.
WHO WOULD YOU WHO?
LOVE FOR YOU TO GET BACK TO US
ON THAT.
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
THIS BURKE SURE JUST BACK TO A
SIMILAR CHOOSE QUESTION
SOMEWHERE IN ONE OF THE REPORTS
A FEELING I REMEMBER AS
STATEMENT ABOUT THAT THE WAY
THAT THE SYSTEM AS PROPOSED IS
DESIGNED IS THAT IT WILL BRING
SMALLER AMOUNT OF DOLLARS TO
MORE PEOPLE HOWEVER LIFT.
LESS INDIVIDUALS OUT OF POVERTY
POVERTY IS THAT RIGHT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
YES YES OKAY SO SO THE THE THE
WAY --
HUNTER WAS ADDRESS L. ELLIE OKAY.
WELL IT IS ONE YEAH SO SO THE
WAY THE THE THE ITC WAS
ORIGINALLY STRUCTURED IT WAS IT
WAS A FOCUSED ON ON THE LOWEST
INCOME TAXPAYERS THE INTERFACE
OUT OF FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
WHICH IS LIKE A QUARTER OF WHERE
THE FEDERAL EITC PHASE OUT.
AS WE'VE BEEN --
INCREASING OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS.
IT'S BEEN INCREASED --
WE'VE BEEN INCREASING IT.
FOR UPPER INCOME.
TAXPAYERS NOT HIGH INCOME BUT
BUT AT THE SOMEWHAT HIGHER THE
SO -- BUT
WHAT WE'VE BEEN GIVING TO THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS IS FAIRLY MEAGER
AMOUNTS YOU KNOW AND SO WHAT
WE'VE WHAT WHAT WE'VE BEEN
FOCUSING ON IS TRYING.
TO BUILD UP THAT THE H. C.
STRUCTURE SO THAT THERE CAN
THOSE.
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS ARE GETTING A A
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT FROM THE
ATC.
SO THAT WAS THE ADJUSTMENT IN
THE P. BECAUSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO DESCRIBE TO ME AT THIS
PROPOSAL IMPACT WOULD BE BROAD
NOT DEEP --
AND SO IS THAT THE REASONING FOR
SOME OF THE ADJUSTMENTS IN WHERE
THE PEAK WOULD BE ON THIS ON THE
GRAPH THAT YOU DIDN'T DO THIS
CRAP I THINK YOU DID THIS CRAFT.
THE KNOWLEDGE OF IT'S THE IT'S
ON YOUR AT CRAP THAT'S ON PAGE
TWO OF THE ASSEMBLY THE AGENDA
[inaudible]
OKAY.
YES --
CAROLINE TO FROM LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THAT THE FIGURE
YOU'RE REFERRING TO IS FROM OUR
REPORT ON AND SPECIFICALLY IN
TERMS OF THE IMPACT ON DEEP.
FAMILIES MOVING FROM DEEP
POVERTY OR OUT OF POVERTY DEEP
POVERTY BEING 50% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL --
MOVES ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND
FAMILIES OUT OF DEEP POVERTY
MAJORITY OF THOSE ARE LIKELY
FAMILIES THAT WOULD BE RECEIVING
THE EXTRA FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
CREDIT BUT WE CAN DIG INTO THAT.
FOR YOU MORE --
TO TO GET A BETTER AND THEN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL MOVES FIFTY
THOUSAND FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY
SPECIFICALLY --
SO IT DOES HAVE A BIGGER PUSH OF
TWO FAMILIES FROM ONE SIDE OF
THE POVERTY THRESHOLD VERSES THE
DEEP POVERTY THRESHOLD.
AND DO WE HAVE ANY REASONING WHY
WE CHOSE.
TO MOVE THE PEOPLE WHO LEAVE THE
TWELVE THOUSAND I MEAN SO IT'S
LIKE FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND RIGHT IN DEEP POVERTY
RIGHT NOW HOW DID WE CHOOSE TO
THE ONLY TWELVE THOUSAND OF
THOSE AFFECTED HIM FIFTY
THOUSAND OUT OF POVERTY.
AND I A I WOULD GO GO BACK --
TO WE HAVE LEARNED OBVIOUSLY
LIMITED BUDGETARY RESIDE GET
THAT AND AND SO.
THE AGENCY THAT WOULD THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY DEVELOPED WAS FOCUS
ON THE VERY LOW INCOME YEAH.
WE'VE BEEN AND AND EACH OF THE
EXPANSION HAS BEEN TRYING.
TO STRETCH IT TO PEOPLE WHO ARE --
WHO ARE STILL IN IN DIFFICULT
FINANCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES BUT
COULD USE IT IS HOPE AND AND SO
ARE?
EXPANSION FOCUSES ON ON REALLY
GIVING A MEANINGFUL HE IDC TO
THOSE FAMILIES PLUS THE THE
CREDIT FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
CREDIT FOR YOUNG CHILDREN.
FAMILIES WITH YOUNG CHILDREN.
IN THIS PETRIE-NORRIS.
BACK TO A QUESTION ON THE
ALEJO'S ANALYSIS SO I THINK YOU
SAID -- THAT.
YOU WOULD NOT ANTICIPATE FROM
THE FOR THE PROPOSAL AS
PRESENTED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT WOULD HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON WORK FORCE
PARTICIPATION.
AND CAN YOU BRIEFLY TOUCH ON
WAYS IN WHICH YOU THINK WE COULD
STRUCTURE IT DIFFERENTLY THAT
WORKFORCE PARTICIPATION YES --
THE ALTERNATIVE PROPOSAL WE
DESCRIBE ON STARTING ON PAGE
NINE OF OUR REPORT.
IN THAT.
AS SHOWN IN FIGURE SIX ON PAGE
TEN OF THE REPORT.
IT WOULD BASICALLY INVOLVE --
INCREASING THE PEAK ABOUT IT
WOULD KEEP THE EITC PERCENTAGE
THE SAME IT WOULD IT WOULD.
PEOPLE WOULD GET THOSE
PERCENTAGES OVER A SLIGHTLY
BIGGER RANGE OF INCOME AND SO
THE NET IMPACT IS IT SAFE FOR
SOMEBODY WHO IS --
SOUND ELEVEN THOUSAND OR TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF PRE TAX
EARNINGS THEY WOULD GET A MUCH
BIGGER BOOST TO THEIR E. I. T.
C..
THEN THEY WOULD UNDER CURRENT
LAW ARE UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
AND WE TEND TO FOCUS ON A LIKE
THINGS LIKE ELEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR BECAUSE THAT'S
ABOUT WHERE YOU'D BE IF YOU'RE
WORKING ROUGHLY HALF TIME.
AT THE MINIMUM WAGE IN THEM THE
MINIMUM WAGE WE ACTUALLY SORT OF
MISS IDENTIFIES BEING ELEVEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR IT'S ONLY ELEVEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR FOR PEOPLE WHO --
FOR EMPLOYERS WHO HAVE TWENTY
FIVE OR FEWER WORKERS --
IT'S IT'S TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IT'S PART IN TWELVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR FOR MOST PEOPLE
BUT IT THAT DOESN'T.
AFFECT NOW WITH OUR CONCLUSIONS
MUCH IN.
YES YOU CAN SORT OF SEE WHAT
YOU'RE THE SORT OF ALTERNATIVE
WOULD DO IT WITH PEOPLE IN THAT
INCOME RANGE.
I WAS ALSO I WAS KIND OF
INTRIGUED BY YOUR POTENTIAL
PROPOSAL THAT THE EXPANDED CHILD
CARE TAX CREDIT COULD BE AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THE FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR CREDIT.
IS THAT SOMETHING.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS LOOKED AT
AS WELL.
YEAH I'M I THINK I THINK THE THE
PROBLEM --
THE THE THE WEAKNESS WITHOUT
PROPOSAL IS THAT IT THEM THE
THERE THAT MONEY WOULD NOT GO TO
TAXPAYERS TO USE HER USING
INFORMAL CHILD CARE --
SO WOULD ONLY GO TO THOSE WHO GO
THROUGH FORMAL AND SO WE THINK
THAT WOULD LEAVE OUT OF A LARGE
SWATH OF THE POPULATION. FOR THE
L. L. LIKE HERE MORE IN YOUR
VIEW OF THE CONFORMITY.
SURE BRIAN WHETHER FORD WITH THE
OF LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
WE HAD A HAND OUT THAT HAS A CAR
FOR YOU.
HOW WE --
SUGGEST CONSIDERING TAX
CONFORMITY PROVISIONS.
THE GENERAL CLOSER CONFORMITY
BETWEEN THE STATE AND FEDERAL
TAX LAWS IS BENEFICIAL BECAUSE
IT MAKES TAX COMPLIANT SOMEWHAT
EASIER --
MORE OVER --
CLOSER CONFORMITY --
BENEFITS THE STATE AND FILERS
ALIKE --
BECAUSE THEY CAN RELY ON FEDERAL
REGULATIONS AND FEDERAL JUDICIAL
OPINIONS AND INTERPRETING TAX
LAWS.
AND RESOLVING TAX DISPUTES --
THAT SAID YOU MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER THE MERITS OF EACH OF
THE CONFORMITY PROVISIONS --
FOR PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR.
INDIVIDUALLY --
LATER IN OUR HAND OUT AND ALSO
ON ON PAGE FIVE OF THE AGENDA WE
HAVE OUR ASSESSMENT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S CONFORMITY PROPOSAL.
WE FIND THAT THE FIRST FIVE
ITEMS ON THE TABLE ARE GENERALLY
REASONABLE AND THAT ON THE
ARGUMENTS IN FAVOR OF CONFORMING.
ARE STRONGER THAN THOSE AGAINST
CONFORMING --
THESE ARE THE LIMITING NON
CORPORATE BUSINESS LOSSES
ELIMINATING THE KNOLL KERRY
BACKS IT'S NOT OPERATING LOSSES.
CHANGING THE LIKE KIND EXCHANGE
RULES -- TO
JUST ALLOW THAT PROVISION FOR
REAL PROPERTY.
EXCHANGES LIMITING DEDUCTION AND
INCREASING THE FLEXIBILITY FOR
SMALL BUSINESS ACCOUNTING RULES.
SO -- I
THINK THE THE ADMINISTRATION
DESCRIBE THOSE BUT IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THOSE WERE
HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT THAT --
THE END OF THIS --
THE SIX ITEM ON THIS LIST IS THE
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS --
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL --
AS A NEW TAX INCENTIVE PROGRAM --
AS ADMINISTRATION MENTIONED IT'S
MODELED AFTER THE FEDERAL
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS PROGRAM.
THE THE FEDERAL INCENTIVE IS IS
HIS PRETTY SIGNIFICANT AND SO --
OUR MAIN CONCERN IS JUST THAT --
THERE'S INVESTORS BENEFITING
FROM THE PROPOSAL THE ADDITIONAL
STATE BENEFIT MIGHT BE A
WINDFALL TAX BENEFIT FOR THEM IF
THEY WERE GOING TO MAKE THAT
INVESTMENT ANYWAY --
HOWEVER WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE DESCRIBING --
THE DETAILS OF THAT PROPOSAL
THAT AT THIS TIME --
THAT SAID THE GOVERNOR'S
INDICATED THEY'D LIKE THE
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE SOME
INCENTIVE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INVESTMENTS IN CERTAIN GREEN
TECHNOLOGY.
JOBS THE THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THERE'S
A VARIETY OF WAYS FOR THE STATE
TO ENCOURAGE SUCH INVESTMENTS.
AND IT'S NOT OBVIOUS TO US HOW --
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS WOULD BE MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN OTHER APPROACHES
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE LOOK
FOR TO LEARNING MORE ABOUT --
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE LIST
HAVE --
RELATIVELY SMALLER FISCAL
EFFECTS AND MANY OF THEM WERE
RECENTLY ADDED SO WE WE HAVEN'T
REALLY DONE ON AN IN DEPTH
ASSESSMENT OF THEM --
BUT FOR ALL THEY LOOK --
LIKE THEY WOULD MAKE MEANINGFUL
IMPROVEMENTS THE SIMPLICITY THE
STATE TAX CODE INNOCENTLY WORTHY
OF CONSIDERATION --
IN CONCLUSION WE WANT TO CAUTION
THAT THE FISCAL ESTIMATES
PRESENTED HERE ARE HIGHLY
UNCERTAIN.
LARGELY BECAUSE THEY'RE BASED ON
THE FEDERAL ESTIMATES TO VOTE BY
THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON TAXATION
AND THEN ADJUSTED FOR FOR
CALIFORNIA IN ADDITION THERE'S
GOING TO BE TAX PAYER --
CHANGES IN TAXPAYER BEHAVIORS
THAT COULD --
LEAD TO A SIGNIFICANT
UNCERTAINTY ILLUSTRATING THIS
THE THE FISCAL ESTIMATES AND AND
OUR TABLE ARE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
THAN THOSE PRESENTED ON BUT THE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
AND THAT HAS TO DO WITH --
SOME DIFFERENT ASSUMPTIONS AND
HOW TAXPAYERS HOW THAT PROPOSALS
WILL BE -- I
I'VE I BELIEVE THAT JUST IT
DIFFERENT ASSUMPTIONS THAT THEY
GO INTO THOSE AND KIND OF
ILLUSTRATES THAT IT'S HARD TO
TARGET.
A SPECIFIC DOLLAR AMOUNT --
ACCURATELY.
AND SO WE SUGGEST THAT YOU
CONSIDER THE ATC PROPOSAL
INDEPENDENTLY FROM WHETHER OR
NOT TO CONFORM TO ANY THE
FEDERAL TAX CHANGES.
OF BOTH DESERVE LEGISLATIVE
DELIBERATION ON REGARDLESS OF
THE REVENUE A FAX --
WE RELEASED A REPORT LAST. TWO
THAT THAT ALSO ASSESSED A FIVE
OTHER OF THE MAJOR CHANGES MADE
IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN LAW AND
WE CAN DISCUSS THOSE IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED [inaudible]
ISSUE.
I WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON ONE OF
THE SPECIFIC CONFORMITY PROPOSAL
ITEMS AROUND OPPORTUNITIES OWNS
AS A CHAIR THE HOUSING COMMITTEE --
I REMEMBER A FEW WEEKS AGO --
WHEN GOVERNOR NEWSOME LAID OUT
HIS BUDGET PROPOSAL YOU TALKED
ABOUT COMBINING ENHANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS ON TOP OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS IS THAT WHAT THIS PROPOSALS
ABOUT IN CAN YOU SEND US ANY
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT?
HOW YOU'RE PLANNING TO SPEND --
EIGHTY SO.
THE I I DON'T I DON'T I THINK
THEIR FEE A LOT OF THE ENHANCED
IN V. I. G. I. IT'S EASIER YEAH
EIFS.
RIGHT HERE THE I. F. T. IS THIS
AND SINCE THAT ARE.
YEAH YOU HAVE TO USE --
ARE WOULD BECOME.
A CO EXISTED WITH OPPORTUNITIES
AND I THINK --
THE THERE WOULD THERE WOULD BE
ANY SORT OF WELL I I REALLY
CAN'T SPEAK TO HOW HOW THE
COORDINATION WORK.
I KNOW THAT THE OPPORTUNITY THE
IDEA OF THE OPPORTUNITIES OWNS.
WOULD BE TO PROVIDE.
TAX BENEFITS. FOR INVESTMENT IN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INVESTMENT IN
PROJECTS.
THAT BENEFIT LOW INCOME HOUSING --
SO AT THAT THAT IS HOW THE
OPPORTUNITY SO WE WOULD BE
SEPARATE FROM WHATEVER THE III
YEAH I F. T. IS DOING --
PROVIDING --
INCENTIVES FOR INVESTORS TO
INVEST IN LOW INCOME HOUSING IN
THE OPPORTUNITY SO.
COULD WE GET SOME MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS ITEM I'LL
JUST NOTE THE SIZE OF THIS ITEM
IS THE SIZE OF THE CURRENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAX CREDIT SO
IT'S A BIG TICKET ITEM.
AND THERE'S ONLY TWO LINES OF
DESCRIPTION ABOUT IT SO JUST
LOVE TO LEARN MORE I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF LOT OF
QUESTIONS.
THROUGHOUT THIS MAN AND WHAT
EXACTLY IS MEANT BY THIS IN AND
WE ARE WE'RE WORKING OUT WITH
THE OBVIOUSLY THE WHAT'S THE
DEFINITION OF LOCALES WHO WERE
WORKING ON THAT --
AS WELLS DEFINITION OF GREEN
TECHNOLOGY --
SO WE'RE WORKING ON THOSE THINGS
THEY HOPE TO HAVE SOME TEA SOON
COME BUT I THINK OF I THINK THE
MODEL WE MAY BE LOOKING AT WOULD
BE LOOKING FOR THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING.
IS THAT IT WOULD --
MATCH WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX WOULD HAVE
THE SAME SORT OF STRUCTURE IN
PLACE THEREFORE VERIFYING THAT
THE THAT THE MONEY IF IT IF IT'S
QUICK LOOKING FOR TO GIVEN IT'S
SUCH A HUGE POTENTIAL CHANGE IN
ITS.
WITH VERY LITTLE INFORMATION AND
I DO KNOW THE GOVERNOR PLIGHT I
UNDERSTOOD THE GOVERNOR WAS
GOING TO PUT OUT A PROPOSAL
AROUND THE INTERSECTION OF THE
I. FDA'S WITH OPPORTUNITY SOUNDS
AND YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE NOT.
SURE IF THIS IS IT.
YEAH I'D BE SOMETHING ELSE YEAH
I'M I'M I'M ACTUALLY NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE HOUSE OKAY SO
IF WE COULD GET A BRIEFING ON
THAT THAT CERTAINLY.
AND AND JUST --
TO CLARIFY THAT REVENUE ESTIMATE.
IS -- IT HAS
NOT BEEN PROPERLY SCALED DOWN SO
PRESUMABLY THE REVENUES GOOD
THIS WAS A REVENUE FOR FULL
CONFORMITY WITHOUT.
ANY --
WITHOUT ANY LIMITATIONS OFF FOR
LOW INCOME HOUSING OR CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY THAT SORT OF THING.
SO THE REVENUE WOULD ACTUALLY BE
LOWER THAN THIS.
ONCE WE PUT IN THOSE LIMITATIONS
WHICH HAPPENED HAVEN'T DONE
THOSE LIMITATIONS.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MR TING.
THANK YOU MISTER --
JUST TO ASK LA AS SO JUST
REGARDING THEIR REVENUE
PROJECTIONS ON THE TASK OF
FORMALLY PACKAGE DID YOU AGREE
WITH THE ASSESSMENT.
OF PERHAPS ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION MOBILE FOR BILLY EXCUSE
ME I'M GOING.
OVERALL IT'S IN THE RIGHT ORDER
OF MAGNITUDE BUT IT.
THE THE LEVEL OF UNCERTAINTIES
IN THE TENS TO POSSIBLY LE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
DEPENDING ON THE WAY TAXPAYERS
TO CHANGE THEIR BE THE EXISTING
FEDERAL THE THE TEXTURES OF RT
CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND WE DON'T KNOW.
EXACTLY HOW YET THE THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD DOESN'T KNOW
HOW YET WE WON'T RECEIVE.
MORE INFORMATION ON TAXPAYER TAX
FILER BEHAVIOR FOR THE EFFECTIVE
TAX YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOR A
MANY MONTHS.
AND AND SO IT'S IT'S DIFFICULT
TO ESTIMATE AT THIS POINT WHAT
WHAT OUR STATE CONFORMITY. TO
THOSE PROVISIONS FOLLOWING THE
FEDERAL CHANGES WILL BE --
THE THIS THIS LOOKS LIKE IT'S IN
THE GENERAL ORDER OF MAGNITUDE.
SO SO FOR YOUR ANALYSIS YOU JUST
ACCEPTED FINANCES ASSUMPTIONS
YOU DIDN'T.
READ IT'S BASED ON THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD THE FTV IS AS FTP DID
BOTH THE IN OFFICE FOR ABOUT
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
AND THEN --
JUST REGARDING E. I. T. C. FOR
SECOND YOU HAD MENTIONED OUTSIDE
OF THE PROPOSAL.
AROUND THE THE TEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR MARK DID YOU HAVE OTHER
EVEN TO MENTIONED IN YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT --
OTHER IDEAS THAT YOU THOUGHT
WOULD MORE TARGET SPECIFIC
POPULATIONS [inaudible]
YEAH -- WE
INCLUDE IN THE IT TOWARD THE
BACK OF THE REPORT THE PROPOSAL
THAT -- I
WAS MENTIONING EARLIER TO EXT
YEAH EXTEND THE THE PHASE IN
RANGE OF THE THE CREDIT SO THAT
YOU HAVE YEAH BASICALLY YOU GET
JUST GIVE A BIGGER CREDITS FOR A
LOT OF ENTER YOUR THAT WITH THE
GRAPH WHICH IS MAKES IT EASY TO
UNDERSTAND HIS.
OR EASIER TO UNDERSTAND IS ON
PAGE.
TEN AND SO THAT REALLY KIND OF
IT.
SORT OF VISUALLY DESCRIBES WHAT
IT DOES --
FOR THAT'S FOR A HOUSEHOLD WITH
TWO DEPENDENTS FOR A HOUSEHOLD
WITH ONE DEPENDENT.
IT WOULD.
THE GRAPH ITSELF WOULD LOOK THE
SAME BUT IT WOULD BE SHE WOULD
BE SCALED DOWN SO IT WOULD
BECOME AT A LOWER.
INCOME RANGE --
FOR THREE DEPENDENTS IT'S
ROUGHLY THE SAME AS WITH TWO
DEPENDENTS IS THERE A LOWER COST
OR HIGHER COST WE TRIED TO SET
THIS UP SO THE COST OF THAT
PROPOSAL WOULD BE SIMILAR TO
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING.
NOW ONE THING OUR PROPOSAL DOES
NOT INCLUDE IS IT IT DOESN'T
HAVE THE FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
FOR P. FOR HOUSEHOLDS WITH AT
LEAST ONE KID UNDER THE AGE OF
SIX SO BASICALLY WE TOOK THAT
WHOLE.
ROUGHLY SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN SEE HOW FAR IT UP WE
COULD PUSH.
THE THE THE MAXIMUM EITC AMOUNT
AND SO IS IS IT AS IT TURNED OUT.
WE THINK THAT YOU COULD INCREASE
THE AMOUNTS BY 42% FOR ALL TYPES
OF FILERS.
AND THAT WOULD A NO COST ROUGHLY
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
IN AND SO THE AYE THE IDEA IS TO
TRY TO GET.
WELL TO AN INCOME LEVEL OF
ROUGHLY. TWENTY THOUSAND WHO
WHAT WHERE ARE YOU TRYING TO
BECAUSE THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT
OF VIEW IDC'S TRY TO GET THEM TO
A MINIMUM AMOUNT OF INCOME.
WELL IT THE WHOLE I GUESS THE IT
HAS THEIR DIFFERENT OBJECTIVES
AT THE A. T. C. HAS AND SO.
THE THE OBJECTIVE OF A PROPOSAL
LIKE THIS WOULD BE --
TO TRY TO DRAW MORE PEOPLE INTO
THE WORK FORCE AND TO PROVIDE
BIGGER BOOST FOR PEOPLE SORT OF
IN THE TEN TO TWENTY TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR INCOME RANGER
MAY BE SLIGHTLY LOWER IF THEY
ONLY HAVE ONE DEPENDENT.
AND YOU'RE SAYING THAT THAT BOTH
PROPOSALS DUE THAT FORMS ARE
JUST -- THE
VOTE THEIR ALTERNATIVE THAT WE
DESCRIBE WOULD HAVE MORE OF AN
IMPACT ON THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD YOU KNOW.
TARGET BENEFITS FOR FIRST OF ALL
THE PEOPLE WITH KIDS UNDER AGE
SIX WOULD EACH GET THAT FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND SECOND.
PEOPLE GENERALLY BETWEEN --
SAY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF INCOME WOULD
TYPICALLY SEE THE BIGGEST
INCREASES.
IN AND WHY WHY WOULD --
WHY DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THEY
WOULD DROP PEOPLE INTO THE
WORKFORCE BECAUSE IT PROVIDES A
BIGGER -- A
BIGGER SORT OF AFTER TAX INCOME --
WAGE SUBSIDY TO PEOPLE --
WORKING ABOUT WORKING HALF TIME
IN PARTICULAR.
DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD BE THAT
THAT WOULD BE AN INCENTIVE FOR
PEOPLE TO COME IN.
YEAH THE EVIDENCE SUGGESTS THAT
THE I. T. C. --
DOES SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
WORKFORCE PARTICIPATION
ESPECIALLY AMONG --
AMONG --
SINGLE MOTHERS.
GREAT THANK YOU.
NO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MY GOD OPEN UP PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE OCEAN IS BIG ON THE SIDE.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON TERROR
COOPER AND HER BURKE --
MY NAME'S NAY AT LEAST ON THE
WILD WITH UNITED WAY SO
CALIFORNIA --
UNITED WAY FIGHTS FOR OR THE
HEALTH EDUCATION AND FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF EVERY PERSON IN
EVERY COMMUNITY.
I WANT TO COMMEND THE COUPLED
THOUGHTFUL THOUGHTS OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBER SPECIALLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKSON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHU ON AYE TENSE --
I'M ALSO PART OF A COALITION OF
OVER TWENTY ORGANIZATIONS WHO
ARE HAVE BEEN COMMITTED TO
STRENGTHENING --
THE KELLY I TO SEE --
WE APPLAUD THE IDC TO REACH MORE
CALIFORNIANS --
LIKE WAYS --
WALL WERE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF
EFFORTS THAT RAISE REVENUE TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM --
WE THINK THE MERITS OF THE
PROGRAMS HAS DONE ON THEIR OWN
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY --
AND IT'S ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE TOOLS WE HAVE TO LIVE
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY --
TRUE TO OUR MISSION AND WE ALSO
STEMPEL SUPPORT OF NOT ONLY
IMPROVING THE CREDIT BUT ALSO
CALLIE I TO SEE BEING AVAILABLE
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS WHO MEET
INCOME ELIGIBILITY INCLUDING
WORKERS WHO FILE WHAT THE NIGHT --
TEN HOWEVER CURRENTLY ITEM
FILERS ARE NOT ELIGIBLE IN THIS
EXCLUSION REALLY DOES HER
FAMILIES BECAUSE EVEN IF ONE
PARENT IN THE HOUSEHOLD DOES NOT
HAVE A NIGHT --
TEN THE CHILDREN IN THE
HOUSEHOLD SO GET EXCLUDED FROM
RECEIVING THE CREDIT --
AND THIS EXCLUSION RESULTS IN
MANY --
CHILDREN INCLUDING US CITIZEN
CHILDREN BEING THE NIGHT THE
BENEFITS OF THE RTC --
ROSSO RECENT CHANGES THEN
FEDERAL TALKS LARA --
FURTHER HURT FAMILIES AND
REFINANCE --
REFUNDABLE CREDITS LIKE THE
CHILD TAX CREDIT WHICH IS NOT
REFUNDABLE FOR THOSE --
WHAT I TENTH --
SO WE CALL IN OUR STATE TO
ADDRESS THIS INEQUITY THROUGH
SMART AND POLICY IMPROVEMENTS
AND WE THINK WE CAN DO THAT --
UNITED WAY RUNS OVER --
SIX HUNDRED BY NO FREE TALK
SITES THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
SO WE SEE FIRSTHAND THE IMPACT
THAT THE CREDIT HOUSE ON THE
FAMILY SAYS WALLACE --
SOME OF THE YOU KNOW HOW HOW
SOME OF THESE EXPLOSIONS ARE
HURTING FAMILIES --
SO WE YOU KNOW ARE ENCOURAGED BY
THE FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET --
ADDRESS BY --
YOU THE STAFF COMMENTS AND WILL
LIKE TO ALSO SEE A CONTINUED
INCREASE ON THIS MULTI YEAR
INVESTMENT OF OUR TIME PROPOSAL
THAT REMOVES THE EXCLUSION OF I
TEN FILERS.
AND ALSO TO CONTINUE INCREASE
MULTI YEAR FUNDING FOR OUR
REGION FREE TAX PREP THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS SASHA
FELT SEEN I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND AS PART OF THAT
CALLIE ATC COALITION I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT KELLY ATC.
AND TO STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
REMOVE HARMFUL EXCLUSIONS FOR
IMMIGRANT TAX FILERS.
OUT WE SUPPORT AND APPLAUD
GOVERNOR MUSINGS PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND AND STRENGTHEN CALLIE ATC
AND WE SUPPORT EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THAT AN EXPANSION IS ADEQUATELY
FUNDED.
HOWEVER WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED
THAT THESE CONVERSATIONS TO DATE
HAVE NOT HAVE CONTINUED TO
EXCLUDE IMMIGRANT FAMILIES.
THE HTC HAS DONE MORE THAN ANY
OTHER PROGRAM TO LIFT FAMILIES
OUT OF POVERTY.
IT'S BEEN SHOWN TO PROMOTE
EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS WHOSE LOCAL
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND MOST
IMPORTANT IMPROVE CHILD AND
MATERNAL HEALTH.
HOWEVER EVEN THOUGH IMMIGRANTS
CONTRIBUTE A THIRD OF
CALIFORNIANS GDP AND ARE VITAL
TO OUR ECONOMY THOUSANDS OF LOW
INCOME WORKING IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES ARE EXCLUDED FROM THIS
TAX CREDIT.
INCLUDING AYE TEN FILERS AND
THOSE WITH DOC AND HE PS WHO
LOSE THEIR IMMIGRATION RELIEF BY
THE WAY.
THIS EXCLUSION NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS ADULTS AND CHILDREN
ALIKE AS MANY IMMIGRANTS LIVING
MAKE STATUS HOUSEHOLDS WERE US
CITIZEN CHILDREN ARE UNABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM THE CAL ATC BECAUSE
OF THEIR PARENTS IMMIGRATION
STATUS.
SOME OF OUR PARTNER SO WE'VE
SPOKEN WITH ON THE GROUND DEEPLY
UNDERSTAND HOW EVEN A MODEST TAX
CREDIT GOOD SOMETIMES MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PAYING FOR
BASIC NEEDS SUCH AS MEDICAL
EXPENSES RENT.
BEING ABLE TO SAVE FOR
RETIREMENT ARE NOT BEING ABLE TO
DO SO.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION REGARDING
THE FEES OF YEAR IT MADE IT
PRETTY FAR ALONG IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS --
WE ALSO WORKED ON EXPANDING THE
CREDIT FOR SELF EMPLOYED
INDIVIDUALS AND WE WERE ABLE TO
FIT FIGURE THAT OUT SO I THINK
WE CAN FIGURE OUT THIS --
TO WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
INCLUDE ALL AND MAKE.
INCOME ELIGIBLE TAX FILERS IN
THE CAL YET YOU SEE TO ENSURE
THAT OUR STATE'S INVESTMENTS IN
FIGHTING POVERTY WORK TO FIGHT
POVERTY FOR EVERY CALIFORNIAN
AND THAT OUR ECONOMY TRULY WORKS
FOR ALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO THANK YOU TEAR COOPER IN
CHAIR BURKE MY NAME IS TERRY
OLEY I'M WITH THE ECONOMIC
SECURITY PROJECT ACTION.
ROUTE ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING INEQUALITY POVERTY IN
AFFORDABILITY AND WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSED ON USING THE MOST
EFFECTIVE TOOLS WE HAVE AND
THAT'S THE EITC SO I THINK YOU
FOR SO MUCH ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE AND ALL OF THAT THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSION THAT WE'VE HAD
ALREADY TODAY.
WE APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR'S COST
OF LIVING REFUND PROPOSAL IS A
GREAT FIRST STEP AT REALIZING
THE PROMISE OF THIS PROGRAM TO
ADDRESS --
THE NEEDS OF SO MANY PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA.
I PARTICULARLY WANT TO CALL OUT
THE GOVERNOR'S CALL TO DISPERSE
THE REFUND AND MONTHLY PAYMENTS
I APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
THAT WAS HAD HERE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY FOR
CLARIFICATION THAT --
THERE IS ANOTHER WAY I AGREE
THAT IS IN THE BEST CASE
SCENARIO A REAL TIME IT
DISBURSEMENT OF WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE KIND OF PREDICTING
EARNINGS ACROSS THE YEAR.
COULD BE COMPLICATED BECAUSE OF
THE WAY WE STRUCTURE THE ATC IN
CALIFORNIA BUT I WOULD URGE --
ALL THIS TO EXPLORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO CREATE A
DEFERRED PAYMENT WHICH OR COMBO
WHERE IF THERE'S A FLAT LIKE
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR CREDIT TO
HOUSE SO YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING
TO GET BECAUSE OF HAVING A YOUNG
CHILD.
GREAT THAT CAN BE DONE AHEAD OF
TIME BUT YOU COULD MONTHLY
PAYMENT OF LAST YEAR'S TAX
EARNINGS IN THIS YEAR WHICH
STILL HAS THE EFFECT OF BLUNTING
SOME OF THE VOLATILITY.
ADD THAT MANY LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS EXPERIENCE SO I'D
URGE PEOPLE TO EXPLORE THAT --
AS WELL I WOULD LIKE TO CALL
ATTENTION TO SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
HERE TODAY AND REALLY URGE --
YOU ALL TO CONSIDER THEM AND
EXPLORE THEM FOR THIS YEAR --
THE FIRST AYE ONE ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES AROUND INCLUDING AYE
TENS I THINK THIS IS JUST
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AND I'LL
JUST.
INCORPORATE WHAT THEY SAID AS MY
OWN COMMENTS AS WELL --
SECOND IN ADDITION TO
MODERNIZING THIS PROGRAM WITH
MONTHLY PAYMENTS --
I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE US
MODERNIZE WITH AN AUTO FILING --
OPPORTUNITY ERIN OUT OF FILING
PROGRAM.
THINKING ABOUT AFFECTED
BEHAVIORAL ECONOMICS THIS WOULD
BE PROVIDING A REALLY POWERFUL
KNOWLEDGE TO PEOPLE WHO--
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO MENTION
OFTENDON'T FILE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE TO AND REACHING OUT
TO THEM WITH INFORMATION THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE LET'S USE THIS DATA
TO OUR ADVANTAGE.
IT REALLY WOULD BRING MORE
PEOPLE INTO THE PROGRAM.
AND I WOULD LOVE TO SEE US LOOK
AT READY RETURN AS A AS A MODEL --
FINALLY I AGREE WITH --
COMMENTS THAT MADE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEEKS AND SHE
KING ISING THE IMPORTANT BUT
UNPAID CARE GIVING THAT HAPPENS
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL --
TO PROVIDE A FIVE DOLLAR CREDIT
GETS AS PART WAY THERE OF
RECOGNIZING CARE GIVERS AND I
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE US A
LOOK AT EXTENDING THAT OUT TO
CARE GIVING FOR ADULT DEPENDENCE
LIKE ELDERLY AND ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
AND THINKING ABOUT INCREASING
THAT SO THAT WE REALLY ARE I'M
CALLING ATTENTION TO THE UNDER
RECOGNIZE BUT VERY --
HARD WORK OF CARE GIVING IN THE
STATE THANK YOU.
WHEN YOU?
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TERRY BRANHAM
HALF OF S. YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA --
I FIRST TAKE I JUST WANT TO SAY
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA A LEAD THE NATION.
IN A PROGRESSIVE RESPONSE TO
WHAT HAPPENED AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WE HAD A HUGE TAX BREAK TO
THE WEALTHIEST INDIVIDUALS IN
THE NATION.
AND THIS PROPOSAL TAKES A SMALL
PORTION OF THAT.
THROUGH CONFORMITY AND PAYS FOR
A BENEFIT FOR WORKERS WHO GOT
NOTHING.
OUT OF THE FEDERAL TAX BREAK A
COST PENNIES ON THE DYING TO DO
THIS AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU. TO
WORK FORWARD WITH A CLEARLY IT'S
GOT SOME ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED THE I TEN ISSUE THE
AUTOMATED TO ROMAN.
I WOULD ALSO CAUTION YOU LOOK
VERY AT THE OPPORTUNITIES
OPPORTUNITIES OWN PROPOSAL WHICH
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO EAT UP ALL
THE REVENUE YOU USING TO PROVIDE
THEIR SUPPORT NOT CAREFUL IF WE
DON'T FENCE IT PROPERLY.
OR CAP THE GROWTH OR REMOVED
FROM THE PROPOSAL ALTOGETHER --
YOU MAY NOT RAISE THE MONEY
YEARS YOU'RE THINKING OF IN THE
LONG TERM.
WHERE STRONG SUPPORT OF WORKING
FORWARD WITH THIS AND APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION?
THANK YOU --
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AIMED
AND CHAIRS MY CAROL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY --
LIKE I SEE ARE YOU WE SEE THIS
IS A REALLY GREAT OPPORTUNITY
THIS YEAR TO REALLY DO. TO
REALLY ADDRESS INEQUALITY IN OUR
STATE ALL WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE
AND THANKFUL FOR THE PROPOSAL
THE GOVERNOR'S BEFORE WE KNOW
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY ONE OUT WE
KNOW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE HAS
ANOTHER PROPOSAL THAT WE'RE ALSO
SUPPORTING --
I DO WANT TO UNDERSCORE HOWEVER
THAT YOU KNOW WE DO AGREE WITH
THE COMMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE
AROUND I TENS AND AROUND THE
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS AND AND FOR
THEM TO BE CAREFULLY CONSIDERED.
AND LASTLY I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEES IN THE
MEMBERS TO HAVE AN OPEN MIND ON
THE ISSUES RELATED CONFORMITY --
WHEN WE SUFFERED THE BIG BUDGET
CUTS BACK A TEN YEARS AGO?
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS WERE THE
FIRST ONES TO GET HIT.
AND NOW IN THE MEANTIME AND
SINCE THAT TIME RATED A CHILD
POVERTY SUB ACCOUNT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE FUNDS GOING INTO
THE TOWERS PROGRAM.
LAST YEAR WE WERE ABLE TO CREATE
A SAFETY NET RESERVE FOR A CAL
WORKS IN THE MEDICAL PROGRAM
THESE ARE SMART IDEAS THIS MEANS
THAT WE HAVE REVENUE FLOWING
INTO THESE PROGRAMS THIS MEANS.
THAT IN A DOWNTURN YEAR WE HAVE
MONEY WE CAN LEAN BACK ON TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE LOWER THE
POOREST PEOPLE OUR STATE DON'T
TAKE THE BRUNT OF A BAD BUDGET
YEAR.
SO THESE ARE GOOD REASONS WHY WE
SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT DOING
CONFORMITY IN ADDITION TO THESE
GREAT IDEAS AROUND THE TAX
CREDITS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JACQUI
ALONG WITH GRACE AND MANAGING
THE AND CAL PARTYING CALIFORNIA
CAMPAIGN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
DIALOGUE AND THANK YOU FOR THE
FOCUS -- OF
THE MEMBERS AROUND THE POVERTY
WE KNOW THAT FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
LIVING THE POVERTY OF 50% --
BELOW THAT PART AND THAT'S FOR
THE RECORD I'M TOLD THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED A YEAR FOR A FAMILY
OF FOUR SO --
FOR MANY OF THAT THAT IT'S HARD
TO MAKE PEOPLE YOU KNOW AND
SMEETON AS YOU HEARD THAT --
WE SAID WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS PROPOSAL --
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO MORE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW CAN
ACTUALLY LIFT CHILDREN OUT OF
THE POVERTY AND KEEP THEM OUT OF
POVERTY I WITH THIS PROPOSAL WE
ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF EXPANSION OF
ITEMS IN THE IN THE EITC
PROPOSAL SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR PERSONS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS NORMA GARCIA I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND ADVOCACY
FOR THE MISSION ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY ALSO KNOWN AS
METTA IN SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA.
META EXISTS TO STRENGTHEN THE
FINANCIAL CAPABILITY OF LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES --
WE ARE A FIGHT ATTACK SITE WE
OPERATE FOUR DIFFERENT LOCATIONS
FOR VITA AND WE FILE OVER FOUR
THOUSAND OF TAX RETURN TO HELP
PEOPLE FILE OVER FOUR THOUSAND
TAX RETURNS. FOR FREE WE KNOW
THE VALUE I TEN HOLDERS IN THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL WE THINK
IT'S ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS TO SHAPE THIS.
AND ON TO ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIA
TO DO WHAT IT CAN TO HELP LIFT
EVERYONE OUT OF THE POVERTY
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO HI MY NAME IS KEVIN AND
SCONE I REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
INTERFAITH COALITION WHICH IS
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE THE NATIONAL.
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN GRACED
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS THE LUTHERAN OFFICE OF
PUBLIC POLICY.
AND CALIFORNIA CHURCH IMPACT AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EXPANDING CAL THE I. T. C. AND
IN PARTICULAR --
TO COVER WORKERS WHO USE IT
TENDS TO CLAIM THE BENEFIT WE
ALSO STRONGLY BELIEVE IT AT
TARGETED CHILD TAX CREDIT THIS
FOCUSED.
ON BRINGING FAMILIES WHO LIVE IN
DEEP POVERTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I TRACY PATTERSON
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
I JUST REALLY AND SO GLAD TO SEE
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND DISCUSSION
ON THIS ISSUE AND ALL JUST
CONFORMIST EIGHT MINUTES WITH
THE UNITED WAY AND THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER WITH THE STRONG
RECOMMENDATION TO INCLUDE I TEN
FILERS -- WE
KNOW THAT IMMIGRANT CALIFORNIANS
MAKE THE BULK OF OUR FOOD CHAIN
WORK FORCE FROM THE AGRICULTURE
ALL THE WAY TO RETAIL AND THE
FACT THAT FOOD AND SECURITY
EXIST AT SUCH A HIGH RATE.
CAN NOT BE SEPARATED FROM
ECONOMIC INSTABILITY SO WE
REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE
THAT DIRECTION AND ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT LOW WAGE WORK IS NOT LOW
WORTH WORK SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE ADVOCATE
ON BEHALF OF SOCIAL WORKERS AND
THE CLIENTS THAT WE SERVE --
WE ARE ALSO PART OF THE
COALITION THAT IS SUPPORTING
THIS PROPOSAL AND I WANT TO
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH WHAT
HAS BEEN STATED PREVIOUSLY BUT
ALSO -- A
SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TITAN FILERS
TO INCLUDE THEM THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION THAT THESE TWO
COMMITTEES ARE HAVING TOGETHER --
I DID WANT TO NOTE THAT I'M --
WORKS TO TEASE A MEMBER OF IT'S
OCCASION TAX COALITION AND OUT
WE HAVE BEEN CONVERSING WITH
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
HORSE YOU ABOUT LOOKING AT MACRO
ISSUE SPECIFIC IN REGARD TO TAX
CREDITS AS YOU CONTEMPLATE --
WERE THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY IS
MOVE ALLOCATE RESOURCES ON WE
DID ALSO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
GOVERNOR'S FEDERAL TAX
CONFORMITY RECOMMENDATIONS
INCLUDED IN THE JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL IN ON WE HAVE RESPONDED.
TO THE LEGISLATURE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE --
WITH A NUMBER OF THOSE ITEMS AS
WELL AS ADDITIONAL ITEMS AND WE
DID COMMUNICATE THAT IN A LETTER
EARLIER THIS MONTH TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
WE HAVE NOT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO FORMALLY DISCUSS E. I. T. C.
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'RE HAVING
HERE TODAY AND WE WILL WORK ON
RESPONDING WITH AN UPDATED
LETTER AS WE FURTHER CHU ON SOME
OF THE NEW ISSUES THAT ARE BEING
DISCUSSED BUT WE DO.
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE TAKING
THE TIME TO DO THIS IN DOING
COURAGE YOU TO INCLUDE FEDERAL
CONFORMITY IN THE OVERALL BUDGET.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIELLE KENDO
KAISER ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
TAX REFORM ASSOCIATION WE ARE AN
ASSOCIATION THAT INCLUDES --
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE GROUPS SUCH AS A
CA YOU AS WELL AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CTA WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
THIS PAST --
WINTER WITH THE LARGER EDUCATION
TALKS COALITION.
AND JOHN MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED A
LETTER FROM OUR GROUP AND
REFLECTING OUR POSITION ON TAX
CONFORMITY IN PARTICULAR --
I'LL NOTE THAT WHILE WE'RE
PLEASED TO SEE SOME OF THE ITEMS
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES.
INCLUDING FEDERAL TAX CONFORMITY.
AND WE SUPPORT THIS EFFORT WE
ENCOURAGE THE ASIAN TO HAVE A
BROADER CONVERSATION AND LOOK AT
CONFORMING TO OTHER SIGNIFICANT.
ASPECTS OF FEDERAL CONFORMITY
WHICH COULD RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE GAINS TO THE
STATE.
ADDITIONALLY WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL FOR
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS AND WE WILL
BE FOLLOWING UP TO DISCUSS THAT
SPECIFICALLY WITH BUDGET
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I LAND ALONG WITH THE
WHITE AMEND GROUP HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
I'LL DISTILLING MY COMMENTS WITH
THE FIRST WEEK OF FROM UNITED
WAY AND I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHT ONCE
AGAIN THAT.
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THOSE --
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WITH
AYE TENDS TO BE INCLUDED IN THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE AND DEAL EVERY DAY --
WITH LOW INCOME --
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES --
LIVING IN POVERTY --
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S THE I. T. C. PROPOSAL
WE WOULD ECHO ALL OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS ABOUT THE I
TEN ISSUE AND JUST ALSO WANT TO
UNDERSCORE.
THAT INVESTMENT IN TAX
PREPARATION AN OUT REACH IS A
VERY IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF ANY
OF A STRONG IDC PROGRAM THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOSH
FRIDAY AND PRESIDENT OF GONE
SAID OPPORTUNITY WE RUN THE
PROGRAM CALLIE ATC FOR ME DOING
OUR EACH ROUND THE EARNING
TAXPAYER ON CALIFORNIA.
JUST REALLY QUICKLY WE'RE
ECSTATIC ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE THE ATC WE
THINK IT'S A HUGE COMPLIMENT TO
THIS BODY --
IN THIS COMMITTEE AND AND WHO
HAS INVESTED IN BUILDING THIS
PROGRAM OF THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF IT TO WORKING
PEOPLE ALL AROUND THE STATE SO
WE'RE EXCITED THAT HE SEES THE
VALUE OF WHAT YOU GUYS HAVE
CREATED INVESTED IN.
WE ALSO --
ARE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
INCREASING --
I TEN FILERS AND LASTLY IF WE
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS THAT JUST
CAME OUT FROM THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD WHERE NEARLY NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FAMILIES ALREADY AT
THIS POINT IN THE TAX SEASON
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM THIS
PROGRAM.
THE INVESTMENT THAT YOU ALL HAVE
MADE INTO OUR REACH AND INTO TAX
PREPARATION IS PAYING OFF IN A
VERY SIGNIFICANT WAY AND WE
THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR JOININGUS
TODAY OUR PRESENTERS SPEAKERS
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING